i now want to introduce you to the
concept of leverage and then in future
videos we'll talk about this more in
terms of what leverage does and when
it's good and when it's bad and we'll
talk about in a lot of different
contexts right now i'll talk about a
little bit more of the context of a bank
so let's say i start off my bank again
and i have 300 gold pieces of equity
300 gold pieces of equity and i use that
let's say
i use that for my building
so building
and that was a hundred gold pieces and
then i have 200 gold pieces that i just
put into my building just to start off
200 gold pieces
let's say i take 100 gold piece deposit
100 gold piece and of course i have an
offsetting checking account
100 checking account that those people
can at any point use either to write
checks or at some point they can come
back and demand their money back
let's say i make out some loans
for different projects
so let's say
300 gold pieces loan a and i do that
just by giving
person a or entrepreneur a or whoever
took this loan out a 300 gold piece
checking account
let me just do one more loan
let's maybe i say i make another loan
for 300
loan
b and i can give that i could have also
issued notes and all of that but
let's say i just give them a checking
account
and we've explored reserve requirements
and all that let's think a little bit
about leverage and leverage is
essentially how much assets do you
control with a certain amount of equity
so in our example right now what is our
equity our equity
our equity is equal to 300
gold pieces so that's equity right there
let me do it in a different color just
so the equity stands out from the
liabilities
and how many assets are we controlling
with that 300
gold pieces of equity so as you have 300
700 thousand so assets
are equal to
one thousand gold pieces so a lot of
times people when they talk about
leverage you might hear someone say two
to one leverage well that means the the
ratio of the assets to the equity is two
to one in this case the ratio of our
assets to equity so we have you know
it's assets to equity leverage is what
people
say
leverage
in this case it's one thousand
to three hundred
or what is that ten to three
ten to three leverage you sell them here
ten to three leverage you'll hear people
talk in terms of ten to one or two to
one or something to one but ten to three
is a is a fair leverage ratio and tells
you just how many assets these are our
assets right here
we're controlling with a certain amount
of equity
and there's a bunch of there's a
i guess a very good reason why a bank
wants to do this because if it's making
money if it's making more money on its
assets that it's paying on its
liabilities
in theory a bank will want to take on as
much leverage as possible right because
with this original 300 investment every
time it adds some assets and some
liabilities it's going to make a
difference it's going to make the spread
on that money and so it wants to keep
doing that but there's a downside to
leverage because what if the bank what
if some of these loans aren't so good
and let me erase what i just drew
what if some of these loans just don't
turn out to be
so good
so leverage when things are good
when they go on the upside it kind of
multiplies how much money you're going
to make but as you're going to see in
about a second on the downside leverage
also multiplies the loss you would take
so in this situation what happens if
i have a
if i had a
30 percent loss let's say that let's
have a 50 loss on these loans that i
made
in a world without leverage so if i
didn't have all of this leverage if i
just had the same amount of assets and
equity so in an example like this where
my assets are equal to my equity
so 300 and i just have 300 of assets if
my assets go down by 50 percent notice
here i have no liability so this is all
equity
and this is all assets
in this example if my assets for
whatever reason i take a loss if they go
down by 50 my new balance sheet looks
like this
let me scroll down a little bit
my new balance sheet will look like this
and 150. so my equity also went down by
50 percent i took a 50 loss because
maybe i made some bad investments
but now that i have leverage what
happens if the value of my assets get
written down by you know at some point i
determined that loan b they're probably
not going to pay up and loan a maybe
won't pay up so the value of my assets
go down by 50 so i have a thousand
of assets so essentially i'm writing
down my assets by 500. so let's say that
i think loan b is only worth
so if i'm going to write down by 500
let's say i think this is only worth 50
and i think that this is only worth
50. because for whatever reason maybe i
gave these loans out to buy to build uh
real estate or these were loans to
subprime individuals who knows whatever
loans these were they just weren't good
loans and i realized i'm not going to
get 300 gold pieces back i'm only going
to get 50 gold pieces back but in this
situation what does my balance sheet now
look like
now that i had leverage my balance sheet
looks like this i have a
in terms of the building itself then i
have 300
of gold deposits
300 of gold that's this part right here
and then
that first loan shrinks
to 50 only and then that second loan
shrinks to 50.
so now what are my total assets this is
50 and this is 50. so i have 100 plus
300 plus 250 so it's 100. so i have 500
of assets which is consistent with what
i said that our assets go down by 50
because i had a thousand of assets
before
and then what are my liabilities well i
owe this this 300 checking account this
300 checking account because you know he
might have written checks to other
people so it's not necessarily the
person the same person that i lent it to
initially
but i have let's see 700 of liabilities
700 of liabilities
so notice i now have negative equity
right
because
assets are equal to liabilities plus
equity well if my assets are 500 and my
liabilities are 700 then what is my
equity well
my equity is going to be minus 200. so
essentially
i'm broke this bank is out of business
and in this situation
there's a very good reason for people to
want to get their money back there's a
very good reason to have a run on this
bank because frankly even if you gave
this bank all the time in the world this
bank is not going to be able to pay back
its money even if it were able to
offload these loans it still does not
have enough money to satisfy all of the
demand deposits or all of the
liabilities and this situation is called
insolvency
insolvency let me do that in another
color
insolvency
and that just means you don't have the
money you're not good for it remember
when we talked about the reserve ratio
that dealt with illiquidity you wanted
to make sure you had enough gold left
aside that when people came and said oh
i want my gold back then you had gold to
give it to them but if by chance people
ask for more gold than you had it
doesn't mean you're out of business you
just essentially have to tell them oh
well can you wait a little while while i
deal with my assets and wait for those
loans to get paid back you're still
solvent
insolvency is when you actually because
of bad investments you actually end up
with less assets than you do have
liabilities and then there's nothing
left over in the equity column
and that's what leverage is a measure of
because if you have really high leverage
then you you know notice when we had no
leverage you could take a 50 loss really
easy but now that we had even 10 to 3
leverage even a 50 loss wiped us out
and if you had 10 to 1 leverage then
even a 10 loss would wipe you out so
leverage really is a measure of how much
cushion do you have to take losses in
the future anyway before i run out of
time and in the next video i'll actually
talk about how leverage is regulated
within banks but just to give you
another measure of leverage because this
measure i gave you you know if someone
says 10 to 3 leverage it's assets to
equity another one that people often use
often in the investing world is debt to
equity but it's really a measure of the
same thing because if someone tells you
debt to equity you can figure out the
assets to equity but in this case the
debt to equity ratio before i took any
losses it was what my
liabilities are
this you can view that as debt right
because i owe these people that money is
700 and my equity is 300 so 7 to 3 is my
debt to equity ratio anyway see you in
the next video